do we understand why the met has changed
its stance on the publication of sue
gray's report
no we don't and that's the question
that's really troubling people here in
westminster and beyond this morning
because it's not clear at all why on
tuesday the met police said that they
were happy for sue gray's report to be
published in full and yet just a few
days later we get this statement which
changes pretty much everything political
calculations the sugray report timeline
and of course what comes next in all of
that i'll just read you that met police
statement because it is worth having in
full they said this morning for the
events the met is investigating we asked
for minimal reference to be made in the
cabinet office report the met did not
ask for any limitations on other events
in the report or for the report to be
delayed but we have had ongoing contact
with the cabinet office including on the
content of the report to avoid any
prejudice to our investigation
now the met has actually been asked why
they have changed their stance and at
the moment they have no formal comment
to make on that they have indicated in
that statement that they believe there
could be potential prejudice but legal
experts will tell you that most of the
offences that they are said to be
investigating are so-called summary
offences which would only involve a fine
so it's very hard to see how that would
be prejudiced because of course there is
no jury trial there is a potential for
other things to be uncovered but i think
those waters are quite muddy there's
some confusion here about whether
actually this is more a communications
problem it's more a problem coming from
the met police perhaps they haven't
quite got themselves in order things
have moved very quickly here this week
of course we know that the sugray report
was expected earlier earlier on in the
week and the prime minister was due to
respond to that in the commons there was
a long day of waiting on wednesday when
it sounded like it may or may not come
i think the team in the cabinet office
behind the sugree report have been it's
fair to say quite frustrated by these
developments they are now making their
own calculation about what should happen
next do they publish something which
doesn't include those eight events we
don't know which events those relate to
and there is a worry that if they go
down that road then that might mean the
report doesn't have much of a bite to it
it might not fairly reflect what sugray
believes took place within downing
street and across whitehall so it might
not really do the job or she could wait
and hold back until the met finished
their investigation but that could be
weeks or even months and there is some
frustration not just from those in that
team but also beyond people want to see
this report it's been dragging on and on
and there is now a real sense actually
from politicians across the board that
what's happening just isn't good enough
we are starting to get some reaction
from those politicians nicola sturgeon
has said things are getting murky at by
the moment the liberal democrats
reflecting there could be an appearance
of an establishment stitch up that's the
strength of feeling and ian blackford
for the snp had this to say just moments
ago
parliamentarians we should be speaking
with a very clear voice this report must
be published it must be published in
full let's make sure that we hold this
government this prime minister to
account we get answers as to what was
going on this corrosive culture of
partying around number 10.
let's make sure that we hold this man to
account and i mean i'll say to
colleagues right across the house
particularly conservatives they have the
power to remove this man this can't go
on any longer this is an attempt to what
appears to be a whitewashing effort the
only one that wins as i've said is boris
johnson
there will be people out there who want
to know what number 10's involvement
potentially was in this situation
whether or not there was any leaning on
the metropolitan police potentially to
change the timing of this
there has been a question posed of the
prime minister's official spokesman this
morning at the lobby briefing that we
have for journalists that of course
happens every morning they have said
that they believe it is not the case
that there was any intervention by
number 10 with that process and that
it's for the cabinet office to liaise
with police but at the moment as you
asked me at the very start there what
why has there been this change from the
met police we just don't know and there
are many people now who suggest that
actually that is the key question that
needs answering today because it has
huge ramifications for the politics here
and for how things look whether or not
the met police is doing its job properly